hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play pace
avaylo most of you guys aren't any help
at all I mean come on I asked you guys
for help last time and you're like you
you need to put the lights in the circle
and then say your name and flood the
toilet I'm like alright know that I did
that what I wanted to know was how to
get into the smoky room and one guy
emailed me and was nice enough to
actually tell me but you guys I actually
had to go back and get them cuz my save
game with none recent you have to turn
this thing to turn the gas off which is
like impossible to see how are you
supposed to know what you're supposed to
interact with in the amount whatever so
now we can go in their room I think I've
got all of the lanterns or the lamps
oh no there's one more unless that one
okay I think I got most of the lanterns
now and there's a key and is that a few
zebu yes what is that for
oh that must be where the gas line broke
okay so we got music there music room
and we got a key which I'm guessing is
for the room up here
Yes No maybe so no no what's it for then
what could this possibly before is it
for this thing are we better be for this
thing yes key for long oh no I don't
have power but I did I did manage to
find one more scrap of paper so let me
know I did find the possible I just
found a scrap of paper I swear I did I
did who's in here I'm sitting on this
and I picked it up damn it I swear I did
okay so I got four of five challah
photos and I've got another key which
I'm guessing that this key will go for
the other salad that I put off srna's
the sally de profesor Rose no professor
Rose
come on come on yes give me paper socket
shavings out of paper that is paper can
I ski
I think boos is that it no that was in
here amber fuse this one goes all the
way downstairs I remember there was one
downstairs that needs you what's with
the confidential stuff we're gonna crap
what's going on in here
huh mysterious mysteries don't burn go
Coco no no oh I caught a little charred
or I don't know your food Mel golos I
don't know give me what Oh Oh aah
those weren't saved pages of satis a
page that's a shame page I could shave
now just in case
got a fuse in there is anything in here
there's the light yes
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme okay
understand out of the table just Casey
pops up I don't want to be at her Beck
and call let's go okay what's this one
ah no don't give it no give it oh my god
don't kill me don't go away don't go by
now Gavin yes I was very nervous about
that
Oh No Oh No okay it was nice it was nice
enough to actually save my progress
before it crashed I can't believe it
actually did that but it did so I am
happy all right
I am happy now that is all six fuses boo
boo ski let's get this girl dead huh
pronto Li gamma Sarah oh I gotta get her
now come here come here
okay flushing - toilet flushes the
toilet
watch it a toy free boy looks and then
boo boo critics bollocks
onyx nope okay so a specific order watch
okay top al fondo alguma or tada and oh
you got to be a specific order was there
something
there's nothing order that it was a good
week - oh ma hang on let me blow you let
me let me look ma I can't I can't use
that one so guess that's out of the
picture one more and then go back to
heart and one I don't know I can't use
them anymore all flushing so let's go
say your name Alex Alex Alex ah order
wrong again Oh what the hell
I thought it I'm gonna be the favor
before I only said like do I need to do
it three times
food products Pollux onyx well that's
gonna take forever hang on there's got
to be some dumb Chum now right
um I'm not right um little man okay so
there's five points on the pentagram so
if you're if you're to make us song one
two three four five I don't know
one three five two wait one three five
two four let's try that one one three
five two four I don't know I don't know
how am I gonna know one three five I
could have sworn that it was only you
needed two plus three now they're
untouchable I don't know I do not know
but I know how to find out ah on it's
just hid do it three times that's what I
did it's just I don't three times I did
it I knew that disobey percent free
cards I blood three times and I would
Holly oh nice nice and then I got my
visa around Arado AR or dem what are you
talking about did I not get a last page
cuz it said wait a minute
maybe I need to find one more page I
don't know cuz in this in this there now
there are five of four know there are
six oh five at a bar arrow day I just
gotta
why to wait oh no I'm missing step 2
there's a step 2 what is this step 2
what's the second step oh no aah aah
huh who's that it just Amish okay aah
okay all right hang on hang on guys hang
on again what the wait a richer walk on
a day and might a rock a funky no okay
ah bra attorny arrow I saw that that was
turn on the water faucet okay one go in
the bathroom turn on the faucet plus
three times
sorry your name [ __ ] goddamn that was
ridiculous
that was redonkulous that was stupid
I just have to find a matter okay he'll
turn it
oh I prayed to the arrow dodo do dodo do
do better be cool dude hallo alle colics
Alex Alex yeah ha ha ha got it oh wow hi
hi there lady come here I just want to
talk with you
uh-uh everyone oh no what oh well she
gone okay well that was some I guess
good for her she's all dead
um an ankh what how's it I don't even
get to go out the door let's fish I'll
just kill her and that's it okay all
right we're done here
hahaha man it looks credits are tiny I
can't read those well I don't even know
says I don't even know who made this
Skylar I think I can't read any of that
I can't read it's dosbal alright so that
was pasted a low huh whoa I mean if you
think about there were there were three
separate things that you need to defense
in that last level and that might have
been just a bit too much route cramp
that that area was it was kind of
ridiculous some of the things that they
had to find me but all at all
I mean it was still it was pretty good
but it was still part of the fetch
mechanic and then run away so I mean I
don't know what to say about it was good
who's fun I hope you guys enjoyed it you
find out for yourself I'm not gonna make
a judgement about this you find out for
yourself if you liked it and if you
liked it then you plan so hurt don't
know if you like Julie blip but play for
yourselves check it out
links in the description thank you
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos if I've done
way hanging with
nobody hole go do is that new game past
it's okay so enough of that so I'm not
I'm not playing this again so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos I've done and
as always I will see you in the next
video
Janna
ah
your help